[Musik]
also es gibt heute abend mehrere
veranstaltungen im heimathaus gibt es
volksmusik auf keinen fall dann hier
rockmusik im club das hört sich schon
besser an
ja aber die sängerin ist ziemlich
populär ich denke die tickets sind
ausverkauft gibt es keine tickets an der
abendkasse
ich glaube nicht
was gibt es denn sonst noch es gibt noch
einen musical oder wir können ins
theater gehen an der theaterkasse gibt
es bestimmt noch tickets
klingt gut hast du lust meine neffen
nico kennenzulernen
warum nicht
[Musik]
ich bin gestern gäste und jetzt ein
kleines konzert und unseren guten
freundin lisa bastia und nico viel spaß
[Applaus]